crazy question for you crazy when when
you spent time with trump yesterday the
three hours at mar-a-lago was there ever
a conversation of you know
bringing getter and truth together would
they use the pla any conversation like
that or not at all no comment
okay then that's the right strategy
here's the thing um
i think that there are there are areas
of of teaming up i think there are areas
where uh you know more than one platform
can exist in this space certain things i
just won't comment or talk about but
let's just say that uh i'm still
politically speaking i'm still a big
ally they're president and very friendly
with them
i think there's a way for both platforms
and the american people to ultimately
succeed in having additional freedom in
their voice that's probably as far as i
want to go okay got it yeah
again
if a strategy like that were to take
place
it's
a
team up together to go up against an
enemy rather than you competing against
each other because if if their platform
is a different angle then getter is a
different angle uh it's like bringing
instagram and facebook together that was
a domination when that took place it's
like bringing
you know youtube and google together
holy so they went from being
competitors to together
top website i know in america right now
is tick tock they just blew past
everybody because of what they're doing
with their videos going viral but you
got google youtube facebook those three
guys competing for the top four so i
think that would be more of a unified
way to go to war
uh for the next two three years because
i think the alternate i think it's gonna
work i think someone's gonna pull this
off
and do it the right way so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]